hey Youtubers, we are Groot.
There's gonna be a whole bunch of Super Bowl
trailers next week.
This is going to be a breakdown of what's
going on.
If you don't care about the Super Bowl.
Don't worry, most of the stuff posts online.
I'll be doing videos for everything so just
be sure to subscribe to get everything and
make sure to click that bell to enable alerts.
I'll be doing all kinds a Super Bowl giveaways
it'll be great.
So the really big stuf first DC doesn't have
any official Super Bowl trailer is that they've
announced.
That means wonder woman the Justice league
didn't drop any Super Bowl trailer's last
year but their promotional partners like Turkish
airlines aired those weird trailers destination
Gotham city city past to become a thriving
center thanks to a significant grant for my
company Wayne Enterprises Gotham is been restored
to its former so there was stuff dropping
for Batman view Superman that might also happen
with Justice league and wonder woman wonder
woman is coming out way sooner the Justice
league though so if there is any kind of DC
stuff happening will probably be teasing wonder
woman Delgadillo was recently teasing some
behind-the-scenes Justice league stuff doing
voiceover for that they shot the movie there
editing it right now.
Wonder woman is also wrapping scoring the
film there doing the music for but the film
itself is done they're getting ready for a
really big campaign.
So just expect them to tease a little things
throughout the week on social media, but I'm
not expecting any really big trailers during
the Super Bowl.
She and Jason Statham are also doing a separate
Super Bowl ad that has nothing to do with
the DC movies is for like a website company.
They play couple bad asses in a restaurant,
they just beat the shed out of a lot of people
so that's something that's completely different.
A lot of you are also asking about Star Wars
they're not officially buying any airtime
but they been teasing stuff for behind-the-scenes
like the opening title crawl the probably
continue to do that through the week with
a little teaser just behind-the-scenes stuff.
It's still very early, it's not coming out
till December.
So is not can be a whole lot of really big
video stuff happening, but the really good
news is that Marvel definitely has some really
cool stuff they confirm.
There's gonna be a guardians of the Galaxy
to trailer.
So that will me a bunch of new footage they
usually only do a small version of that on
TV and then a longer version online.
So the be a whole bunch of new stuff to dig
through.
I'm not expecting them to reveal ego the living
planet.
But they might explain a little bit more about
the story because they've already released
at first trailer usually that's just like
a mishmash of like the big moments.
The funny things like all the baby Groot skewed
he doesn't know what's going on it's gonna
be crazy.
The next trailer after that is usually a story
based trailer that explains what actually
happened with the villains are doing why the
guardians are fighting this big creature here
why the ravage her to turn against them just
explaining what the hell's going on ego the
living planet is probably going to be saved
for the very last trailer.
They did the same thing with old Tron, when
they were marketing age of old they saved
him for the last trailer and they did the
same thing with Spider-Man when they were
marketing Civil War biggest stuff always get
safer last in guardians is a coming out to
the beginning of May.
So speaking of Spider-Man, everybody freaking
out there supposed to be some new Spider-Man
dropping Sony hasn't officially announced
what they're doing.
But there's going to be some sort of Spider-Man
stuff happening this week.
They bought a Super Bowl trailer for their
last big Spider-Man movie with Andrew Garfield
that movie was coming out earlier in the year
but that's the only really really big movie
that they have coming out that is going to
make bank have a couple of the big movies.
There's a lot of talk about Sony selling its
film business Marvel buying them.
Meaning that they would get all the Spider-Man
characters back.
But that's a whole other thing, so I'll do
a separate video about that explain what's
going on soon if they do drop a legit trailer
it'll be the same deal as guardians just more
stories like this is what the vultures doing
this is what the villains are trying to do
this is how.
Spider-Man starts fighting them.
This is the reason he runs into them so.
Just explain what the hell's going on next
big studio is Fox for the X-Men stuff, which
is Logan.
But they also have the new alien covenant
movie that's coming out later in the year
my bet is that they'll drop some new Logan
because that movie is coming out really soon
that the last trailer.
They dropped they called the final trailer.
So anything new that they drop in terms of
footage would probably be just teasers flashes
of X 23 weapon next up is explaining a little
bit more about the story little bit more of
Hugh Jackman.
Most people are expecting Hugh Jackman to
get people into the theaters most of the comic
book people want to know what's going on with
X 23 the last big other movies is all paramount
stuff that's transformers the last night and
fast and furious.
The funny thing with both of these movies
is that they almost have the exact same story.
The good guys going bad and the bad guys going
good optimist prime poison with dark energy
on going bad Megatron becoming one of the
heroes and then in the fast and the furious
movie.
Dom is being forced to go bad by the villain
and Jason Statham the villain of the last
movie is now working with the heroes, what
a coincidence that they're both trading on
the same themes whatever ends up happening
all totally do videos for all the big comic
book stuff sometimes they'll drop teasers
during the week leading up into like the big
Super Bowl trailer.
So if there's anything cool I will totally
do a video for it but feel free to leave your
request in the comments below, but all that
stuff will start posting on Sunday normally
I try to do game of thrones on Sunday, so
I'll try to schedule around that depending
on what's happening because it will be like
Super Bowl trailers all day long.
It'll be crazy, but it'll be really really
cool if you don't care about the Super Bowl.
Don't worry as long as you have alerts enabled
you just see all the trailers as I post them
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for new Black Panther they to start
filming and infinity war and you can click
here for new Star Wars episode so much watching
five I'll see you in the next video!